oh this one's gonna be
hard to watch
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
in today's highly requested video we
will be reviewing
amber lynn reed now i've received so
many requests from you guys to review
amberlynn since i began this series
but especially since i did my review on
nicocado avocado
so similar to nick whose review you can
watch right here
amberlynn's channel has been the subject
of a lot of hate
a lot of bullying and a lot of
controversy
largely to her extreme weight gain and
the inconsistent nature of her content
and while it has taken me a long time to
figure out how to best approach this
video
i want to say that i think i'm finally
ready
so today we're going to be taking a look
at the evolution of amberlynn's channel
and her corresponding weight gain my
thoughts on her problematic mukbang
content and some of the reasons why
dieting
might be failing amberlynn's weight loss
goals we will also once again be joined
by eating disorder dietitian
alessandra magisano to gain a little bit
more insight into some of these
hot topics but of course before we get
started
a few quick disclaimers number one the
information in this video is for
entertainment
and educational purposes only so you
should always speak to a healthcare
provider about
your unique healthcare needs two this
video is
not intended to diagnose or pathologize
amber lynn
the intention of this video is to simply
discuss the themes on our channel
in an educational and compassionate
format three
don't forget to please be kind in the
comments both here and on amberlynn's
channel
for a trigger warning that some graphics
and discussions
may be disturbing to some my viewers
particularly
those who may have battled or are
battling disordered eating
so of course feel free to skip this
video if that sounds like it could be
you
and finally do not forget to subscribe
to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out
okay so for those of you who are
unfamiliar with amberlynn reed
she initially started her youtube
channel back in 2013
to document her weight loss journey at
the time
she was around 368 pounds however
since starting her channel she continued
to steadily gain up to about 200 pounds
and reached her highest weight in
january 2020 at 572 pounds
now despite trialing a variety of
different popular weight loss diets
during this time
viewers have questioned amber's
authenticity and commitment to her
weight loss journey
as she continues to steadily gain weight
despite repeated efforts to improve her
diet and
start fresh tomorrow now in addition to
her weight loss journey
amberlynn is also known for her mukbang
videos which
have really generated a lot of negative
feedback
critics of amberlynn are quick to point
out some of the contradictions
of someone in a larger body seeking
weight loss who is simultaneously
participating
in a trend that encourages eating large
volumes of food
in one sitting so this begs the question
are mukbangs okay acceptable and
fun to watch when the youtuber is
generally thin healthy
or fit and are they otherwise disturbing
and problematic when the milk bangers
nutritional health
is already in question we're gonna be
diving
deeper into these questions later on in
the video so definitely be sure to stick
around
for that now with all of that said many
of amberlyn's viewers have repeatedly
expressed concern about her size and the
implications that this may have
on her health and well-being now i can
understand this concern
as we do know that obesity specifically
higher amounts of body fat
may put one at a greater risk of a
number of chronic diseases
including cancer unfortunately amberlynn
did recently share that she was
diagnosed with stage one endometrial
cancer
which is a cancer in the lining of the
uterus now i will say that there are a
number of risk factors for endometrial
cancers
including age genetics and use of
certain forms of contraceptives
but research does suggest that obese and
overweight women
with higher amounts of body fat are two
to four
times more likely to develop endometrial
cancer
and extremely obese women are about
seven times more likely
one explanation for this is that excess
fat tissue produces higher amounts of
estrogen
which has been associated with not only
endometrial cancer
but also breast and ovarian cancers
another possible explanation
is that individuals with higher body fat
often have increased blood levels of
insulin and insulin-like
growth factor 1 which may promote the
development of
some cancers including endometrial
cancer but of course
i am not an oncologist nor am i part of
amberlynn's healthcare team
so obviously i cannot speak to the root
cause of amberlynn's diagnosis
but what we can say just by looking at
the research
is that there may be an association
between
higher body fat and the development of
some cancers
now with that said since sharing her
diagnosis
amberlynn has also had a hysterectomy
to surgically remove the uterus so i do
want to of course wish her a
full and safe recovery and remission
from her surgery and condition
now moving on to her diet i do want to
start by acknowledging that amberlynn
has shared
that she suffers from binge eating
disorder and overeating
as usual it is not my place to speculate
about whether or not this is true
and like i said i'm not here to diagnose
or pathologize amber lynn
but rather the purpose of this video is
to review the content
on her channel at face value in a
compassionate and educational format
so as to discuss some recurring themes
like dieting
and emotional eating with that said
i really can't confirm whether or not
amberlynn's what in a day videos
are an accurate representation of what
she actually consumes in a day
but we will talk more about binge eating
disorder and dieting later on
for now i do want to take a brief look
at what amber lynn's typical day of
eating might look like
at the time of filming this video which
by the way is subject to change by the
time that it's live
let's start with her breakfast and a
quick trigger warning
i'm going to be giving some suggestions
on how to help
optimize satiety for amberlynn's weight
loss goals
so if this is triggering for you of
course feel free to skip the section of
this video
so for breakfast on day one we've got a
smoothie with greek yogurt
some frozen berries and some spinach
on day two is a bagel with some chicken
breast
cream cheese and some cheetos and on day
three it's some pasta with
onion tomato corn pesto butter
and some sparkling lemonade so amberlynn
has previously said that she doesn't
usually consume stereotypical breakfast
lunch and dinner meals
instead she will usually just eat
whatever she feels like in the moment
great you know i don't necessarily think
that meals need to look
a certain way based on the time of day
that they're consumed so if that's
something that works for her and her
palette
then it works for me with that said i
think there is some room for improvement
here to really maximize the nutrition of
these meals
which would help keep amberlynn feeling
satisfied longer
potentially curb the desire to binge
later on in the day
and boost the disease fighting
antioxidants in her diet
for general longevity and health so for
example
she could swap the bag of cheetos with
the smoothie from day one
to pair with her bagel breakfast and
this would help cut back on some of the
added salt
and refined carbs while adding in a
serving of fruit veggies
and extra protein from the greek yogurt
she could also choose a nice hearty
whole grain bread instead of the bagel
if she wants some days
which provide a lot more satisfying
fiber
protein and maybe some healthy fats to
really keep her energy levels more
steady
also fyi when i'm choosing a bread i do
like to look for the words
whole grain as the first ingredient in
the list
and ideally i'm looking for about three
to five grams of fiber
and three to six grams of protein per
two slices
so that might be a good guideline for
amberlynn as well
now on day three i really like that
she's got some veggies added to the
pasta
but she could definitely shift the
proportions maybe by throwing in some
zucchini noodles in with the regular
pasta
or a few extra handfuls of frozen
spinach just to up the fiber content
and maybe also add in some tofu or
edamame as well
especially because a 2015 meta-analysis
found that soy intake was associated
with 20
lower endometrial cancer risk she could
also swap her pasta for like chickpea
pasta
because it's got about twice the protein
and fiber on average
as traditional pasta but i would say
that you know just adding in
more protein and fiber to her breakfast
meals would definitely help keep them
a little bit more balanced and up their
staying power to keep her feeling more
satisfied until lunch
and we know also that a
mediterranean-style diet rich in whole
grains
fruits and veggies is associated with
lower risk of endometrial cancer
so just something to really keep in mind
let's take a look at lunch
okay so for lunch day one she's at a
restaurant and she has some tilapia with
cream sauce
broccoli and zucchini looks so good day
two
is just a luna bar for lunch and day
three is a second bowl of that pasta she
had
on day one now with her lunch on day one
which is the fish and veggies from ruby
tuesdays which looks delicious
amber lynn also mentions that even
though this meal
was low calorie it did help her feel
full and i'm really not surprised by
this because if you guys remember
my hunger crushing combo we want to aim
for a source of fat
protein and fiber with our meals so this
meal in particular
is getting protein from the shrimp and
tilapia fat from the cream sauce
and fiber from the veggies so super
satisfying i'm sure and i also love that
this meal is not so like overly
restrictive it's not like
you know plain broiled fish and and
steamed or boiled vegetables we're
getting that cream sauce in there to
make it a little bit more
satisfying so that really helps with
reducing the
idea of kind of mental scarcity as well
on day two amber lynn opts for a luna
bar
and while the luna bar is a great
on-the-go snack
it's just not likely going to provide
enough fuel to get her through to dinner
i mean literally these have less than
200 calories
the problem is if we let ourselves get
too
hungry with low calorie meals we're more
likely to overeat
whatever we can get our hands on really
quick
so even if she didn't have time for a
formal sit-down meal
she could beef this up with like a
handful of nuts a hard-boiled egg and a
piece of toast
or some whole grain crackers hummus and
cut up veggies
so i totally get the amberlynn may be
looking to choose really low calorie
meals
in an effort to lose weight fast but
choosing meals that are just
inadequate is a set up for a binge
so we still want to think about getting
enough calories
particularly from those hunger crushing
compounds to get us
to that next meal and then as for day
three amberlynn has the same pasta that
she had for breakfast
so again we would want to maybe bump up
the fiber and ideally get some
plant-based protein into this meal
to make it more filling and more rich
and also maybe just add a little bit
more variety so we could switch up the
veggies
or serve it with like a green salad to
get our veggie fix
now let's talk about dinner okay so for
dinner on day one we've got
four slices of bread with mayo chicken
and bacon
on day two it's some macaroni with
buffalo chicken sausage and broccoli
and on day three it's a bowl of cereal
then another bowl of cereal
a few spring rolls and then six oreos
so again we're seeing a variety of
different types of meals that don't
necessarily fall into the
standard dinner category which is
totally okay
and as you guys know i am not into food
rules
even ones that say you can't have cereal
for dinner
i mean like this video right now if you
love
breakfast for dinner or like brenner
brenner i guess right yes please
yes please anyway so on day one
we've got those sandwiches with mayo
chicken and bacon
i like that there's more protein in this
meal but we would definitely want to see
some veggies or like a simple side salad
just like
balance things out i also think that
maybe we could go for either the mayo
or bacon since there is already a lot of
saturated fat in this meal
and that doesn't mean we need to skimp
out on flavor or fat or even reduce the
calories
we could totally swap the mayo for like
avocado
and the bacon for some flavored tempeh
to boost up the plant-based protein
this is particularly of interest for
amberlynn because
research suggests that higher saturated
fat intakes
are associated with increases in
endometrial cancer risk
by 60 to 80 percent
all right so then on day two we are
seeing a little bit more balance
you know we've got those carbs from the
pasta we've got some protein
in the chicken sausage and some veggies
in the broccoli
though again i would probably shift the
proportions just a little bit to
see a little bit more green in there and
again maybe that chickpea pasta would be
another easy
swap as for day three obviously you
don't
need me to tell you that it's not a
super nutritious meal with the oreos and
the spring rolls and two bowls of cereal
for dinner
um and amberlynn herself actually
mentions that this was a
bad eating type of day which resulted in
a bit of a binge that occurred
off camera so saying that we need to
boost up the vegetables is
kind of a moot point here but we'll be
talking a lot more about amberlynn's
emotional eating
later on in the video but again this may
come down to a combination of physical
restriction
and the experience of emotional scarcity
but stay tuned because we're going to
talk a lot more about that so in terms
of my overall thoughts on amberlynn's
diet
at least based on what we're seeing in
these 2020 what in a day videos
her portion sizes are not particularly
big
in fact at times they might just not be
big enough and that can set you up for a
binge
really quickly but we do have some
generally
balanced meals to work with there is of
course some room to optimize the
nutrition in some of amberlynn's meals
particularly to ensure that she is
satiated and then not setting herself
up for a binge with inadequate calories
at meal times
and also to make sure that she's getting
in the antioxidants
for cancer prevention so for example
adding in extra nutrition from protein
and fiber would help to make her meals
more satiating
keeping her blood sugar levels in check
and of course
helping to keep her fuller for longer
without adding in
a ton of calories which may potentially
reduce the urge to binge later on in the
day
also focusing on lots of colorful fruits
and vegetables
whole grains beans and soy protein
may help to reduce her risk of future
cancer
but again these videos are just one
piece of the puzzle
and may not be an accurate
representation of how amberlynn eats
off camera or during an actual binge
now one hot topic that i want to get
into is
mukbangs and i've shared my thoughts on
the mukbang trend
which you can watch right here but
essentially
mukbangs on youtube have now evolved
from the korean trend of eating a
modest amount of food in front of an
audience to simulate a social eating
experience virtually to now eating a
large quantity of food in a short period
of time
aka the actual clinical definition of
a binge so obviously to the average
viewer
amberlynn's regular mukbang activity
seems at odds with her weight loss goals
and this of course has led to a lot of
online bullying
vicious diet trolling and accusations
that she isn't taking her health or
weight loss seriously
with that said amberlynn has recently
shared that she's actively trying to
rebrand her channel
without doing milk bangs because even
though these videos generate the most
views
they also generate the most hate and
scrutiny
sounds a lot like what we heard from
nicocado
on his channels as well now what i do
want to point out however
especially in contrast to other infamous
smoke bangers like nick
is that the volume of food in amberlyn's
mukbangs
pale in comparison to the norm
in fact even though we are seeing some
traditional mukbang
foods like flaming cheetos and various
high calorie
highly processed fast foods we're also
seeing a lot of
less typically bingeable and more
balanced meals like
veggie stir fry tuna and celery with
rice cakes
veggie burgers or some meatloafs or with
some mac and cheese
and these meals are often even
accompanied by a side of veggies or
sliced fruit
which let's be real doesn't really
satisfy
a viewer's desire to live vicariously
through a youtuber's epic
cheat meal so amberlynn's mukbangs are
dare i say healthier than most youtubers
all in
10 000 calorie challenges but yet
if you compare the comment sections of
her mukbangs
compared to many others like let's say
always hungry
amber lynn bears the brunt of the
disgust
and hate let's just look at one of the
most
popular comments on amberlynn's mukbang
versus one from lifestyle youtuber
always hungry
both of these people post about wanting
to get or stay fit
but the primary difference is that
olivia adams from always hungry
is already in a socially desirable body
and amber lynn is not
so why does someone's body size
influence our perception about whether
or not mukbangs are acceptable
and why is eating any amount of food
that is not considered
diet food not socially acceptable from
somebody in a larger body
here's the thing i am by no means
condoning mukbang videos of any kind
even the more modest versions on
amberlynn's channel
i honestly think that this is a really
problematic youtube trend
that perpetuates a lot of disordered
eating behaviors
but these behaviors are unhealthy
regardless of size repeatedly eating
large amounts of highly processed foods
in one sitting
can lead to increased blood pressure and
blood sugar
water retention shifts in one's gut
microflora
and dysregulated mood but it's very
clear
that the negative public perception of
anne berlin's content
is unique because of her size
and that's nothing new research suggests
that society's
negative attitudes towards obese people
play a significant role in their
psychological
and their physical health i get that a
lot of people think that trolling an
obese person about their weight or
offering like aggressive dieting advice
might motivate these individuals to
adopt healthier behaviors
but statistically the opposite is true
research shows that the experience of
weight stigma reduces
exercise frequency and increases binge
eating
unhealthy weight control behaviors and
binge eating disorder
in fact one study on more than 2 400
overweight and obese women
reported that 79 of participants coped
with weight stigma
by eating more food and 75 percent of
participants
coped by refusing to change their diet
in addition
weight stigma can also cause
psychological stress
which can increase the risk of
depression low self-esteem
and body dissatisfaction so you can see
how this
experience may actually perpetuate some
of these
unhealthy destructive behaviors
so are internet trolls the reason for
amberlynn's extreme weight gain since
she started her journey online
well according to the research and
simply by looking
at the comment section of even just one
of her videos
i would say that this is a real
possibility
and considering that amber lynn's weight
gain and mukbang behavior
has become so ingrained in her online
identity
she might feel that it's understandably
a really difficult pattern to break now
while my
own personal and professional
experiences see
milk bangs as often really problematic
i'm also totally open to the possibility
that they may play a therapeutic role
for amber lynn in one of her videos
amberlynn mentions that eating in front
of the camera
just actually increases her awareness
around what she's eating
and allows her to eat at a more slow
pace and more mindful pace compared to
how she might eat off camera which is
usually in front of the television
because of this she states that she
actually often ends up eating less on
camera compared to when
she's eating when nobody's watching and
there's a few reasons why this might be
for one it may be that her audience
gives her a sense of accountability with
her weight loss goals
now accountability is an important
element in a lot of weight loss programs
and also in eating disorder recovery
plans in an effort to maintain
some structure around food and normal
eating behaviors
in the context of disordered eating
behaviors which is what i would
characterize
some of the mukbang binging to simulate
the feeling of being watched by
followers on youtube
is kind of similar to what might happen
in
real eating disorder recovery programs
where meals are supervised by a member
of your treatment team
we also know that most eating disorder
behaviors happen
in private so it is statistically
unlikely
that she would invite us the viewer to
witness an extreme
binging episode now the other potential
benefit of the mukbang format
is that amberlynn herself suggests that
eating for the camera
encourages her to eat more mindfully and
slowly
both of which are healthy eating
practices so research suggests that
eating solely without distractions
allows your body more time to release a
tidy hormones
in contrast eating while distracted like
watching tv or on your phone
can lead to faster eating and eating
past the point of fullness
in fact one study found that tv watching
while eating
increased food intake by up to 71
research has also shown that mindfulness
can be a useful tool to reduce emotional
eating
and the frequency of binge eating
episodes both of which amberlynn claims
she struggles with so
once that he found that obese women
doing mindfulness exercises
decreased their binge eating episodes
from four times a week
to one to two times a week that is
powerful stuff
so i can't say that milk bangs are a
hindrance
to amberlynn's weight loss efforts and
it's very possible that the blatant
weight stigma and trolling in the
comments sections of these videos
play a larger role but is an online
troll
really the only cause of such a dramatic
shift
in weight over time so i want to talk
about some of the other potential
contributing factors
to amberlynn's public weight gain
according to amberlynn
she's been classified as overweight for
as long as she can remember
and was just 11 years old when she first
went on a diet
so since then she says that weight loss
is kind of on her mind
24 7 and she really doesn't know what
life is like
without worrying about her weight she
even has a video where she lists 100
reasons why she wants to lose weight
which includes things like reducing her
risk of disease
as well as engaging in seemingly normal
experiences
like dancing traveling and walking on
the beach
so despite people's skepticism of
amberlynn
i think it's pretty clear that weight
loss is something that she strongly
desires
and she recognizes that her weight gain
does have
implications for her quality of life so
why is weight loss
so hard for amberlynn to achieve well
according to the literature
it can be really challenging for a lot
of people to achieve
and maintain weight loss long term
even the most liberal research tells us
that most people who engage in
intentional weight loss behaviors
on average lose and maintain no more
than
six to ten percent of their weight so
for somebody who is
overweight or obese they will likely
remain
in these categories after their maximal
realistic amount of weight loss is
achieved
we also know that there's a high rate of
weight regain
after a period of significant weight
loss also known as
weight cycling so one study found that
individuals typically
regain 30 to 35 percent of their weight
a year later
and will often regain most of the weight
or more
within five years this may be one reason
why amberlynn regained the weight that
she lost those 89 pounds
and continues to gain more this is not
to say that it's impossible to sustain
long-term weight loss
you can find tons of examples of people
who do it every day
and i do believe absolutely that it can
be done
however the data tells us that
maintaining
significant weight loss for over five
years
is more of an exception rather than the
rule
with that said obesity is a complex
issue
and cannot simply be resolved by eating
less
and exercising more if it were that
simple we
probably wouldn't be seeing amberlynn
going on a diet
after a diet to lose weight only to
regain it back
also putting oneself on really
restrictive diets in an effort to lose
weight
often sets one up for a future binge and
amberlynn herself has confessed that
stages of restriction and deprivation
often trigger her to binge and overeat
this is why the new obesity guideline
suggests that rather than suggesting
somebody just
eat less to weigh less it's more
important to focus
more on the root cause of an
individual's weight gain
and healthy behaviors that they can
actually sustain
now one of the many reasons why just
eating less doesn't always work
is that food is often used as an
ineffective coping mechanism
to soothe negative emotions so
amberlynn's documentation
of her emotional eating episodes are
often peppered with depressive episodes
and follow along the typical cycle of
guilt
shame regret and fear of losing control
this is why one of the first steps to
dealing with emotional eating
is to help identify and differentiate
physical and emotional hunger while
working with your therapy team to
really find other effective coping
mechanisms to help manage those emotions
i talk about this in a lot more detail
in my video on emotional eating
which you can watch right here however i
just want to summarize the differences
between
emotional hunger and physical hunger
physical hunger develops gradually
whereas
emotional hunger comes on usually pretty
suddenly or abruptly
often accompanied by some kind of really
strong emotion
emotional hunger often also can drive
you towards
one specific food whereas physical
hunger often is a little bit more
flexible
and more open to what's available
physical hunger often has a clear
endpoint so
you're usually able to experience the
onset of fullness
and take it as a cue to stop eating
whereas when you're eating
out of emotional hunger it's often more
difficult to feel satisfied or
full and when you don't it often
triggers
further feelings of guilt and shame now
before we dive deeper into these topics
with alessandra
i want to talk about amberlynn's current
weight loss plan
since reaching her highest weight of 572
pounds in january
so in an effort to continue to lose
weight and with the weight loss goal of
400 pounds
amber lynn has flirted with weight
watchers noom
and intuitive eating but outside of diet
attempts
her focus has been on curbing her binge
eating episodes
all of which have collectively helped
her lose close to
90 pounds now it's important to mention
that for amber lynn
these episodes are not just benign
binges that can
you know easily be overcome and
forgotten about at the next meal or
snack
there can actually be a difference
between a binge and what amberlynn has
been diagnosed with
which is binge eating disorder so to
dive more into these topics i have once
again invited my colleague eating
disorder dietitian
alessandra magisano to provide her
insight and expertise on the subject
thank you again for joining me
alessandra
oh thank you thank you for having me i'm
so happy to be back so what is the
difference between
a binge and binge eating disorder
okay so great question the main
difference between the two of them is
essentially
clinical criteria uh or diagnostic
criteria
so a binge eating disorder
um is a mental health condition that can
be
technically diagnosed and it follows
very specific
uh quantitative measurements so things
like
eating a certain amount of food in a
specific amount of time
um generally larger than someone
would eat uh comparably to to to you
and it also involves some qualitative
measurements like
feeling guilty feeling uncomfortably
full eating when not hungry
things like that but it's more
quantitative in terms of
recurrent episodes of binge eating at
least once a week they say
in the past three months whereas a binge
first of all could be on something other
than food
and it's more subjective in nature it
can be more subjective so
someone can eat a cupcake and feel like
it's a binge and that is completely
valid
so that's the main difference between
them they're very similar
really almost identical the only
difference is one
kind of is clinical and checks off boxes
and the other one can actually be more
subjective
and takes into consideration more
qualitative components
amazing good to know and regardless of
diagnosis
what are some strategies to help kind of
curb
overeating and those binge cycles
the main number one strategy
for both is meal regulation
so whenever someone is experiencing
either overeating cycles or binge eating
cycles
it is because of some element of
what we call chaotic eating or eating
that either doesn't satisfy
enough physically or emotionally or
mentally
so we want to look at it's widely known
that binging comes from some element of
restriction that's
thankfully now pretty well known
um but there's this other component of
mental restriction that is
less often understood and that's what i
like to focus on with my clients as well
is this idea that your meal regulation
is not just about going through the
motions of eating
enough food quantitatively but it's also
about
feeling satisfied and feeling like it's
it's um enough and that you're fueling
yourself
often and one of the biggest struggles
that i
see in in my clients is they often ask
me okay but i'm working on my overeating
but i feel like i'm eating more you're
telling me
too much and that's the biggest struggle
because ultimately it feels like they're
eating more when really we're
taking away the binging and we're taking
away maybe the grazing
and the most important thing is we're
taking away the mindless eating
that they weren't even aware they were
doing so they don't really count that
but when i'm like okay
for lunch have a sandwich and some
veggies and hummus and a piece of fruit
they're like that's a lot of food that's
a lot of food
but it does it feels like it is because
it's mindful intentional
so that's really the main strategy when
we want to curb is meal regulation
and satisfaction amazing great tips and
in your opinion
why do a lot of weight loss diets fail
individuals who suffer from binge eating
disorder
well i think weight loss diets fail
everybody
and and i think in one re one way they
really
are unfair to people who suffer from
binge eating disorder and
and overeating though is because they're
often
again there's this stigma of that binge
eating and overeating is about eating
too much a loss of control
and the willpower so weight loss diets
offer this wonderful solution to just
kind of fixing that
but it fails them ultimately because
it's not about
um it's about deprivation again not just
physically but
mental deprivation but it pulls on their
heart strings of
you're not good enough like you're just
not doing it right like if the diet
didn't work
you you eat too much that's the problem
so it it really it they really is hard
on them
because they're disadvantaged in terms
of the stigma of binge eating
and and overeating for example
so insightful and is there often a focus
on weight loss when treating
people with binge eating disorders or is
this just like too triggering for the
most part
definitely too triggering it's a very
much um counter-indicated so we would
never uh focus on weight loss at all at
least at the beginning stages of
treatment
so just like how we would with someone
who was suffering from anorexia or
bulimia or any other type of eating
disorder we wouldn't
weight loss cannot happen in recovery
in terms of that can't be the focus of
the goal because often remember it's the
symptom
right like wanting weight loss is a part
of a symptom
it doesn't mean it can't happen or can't
be addressed but it needs to happen
within the process
in order for it to to work otherwise it
is too triggering and it gets in the way
because then it's just about
okay but like the progress is about
weight loss which
um negates all the other indicators that
we try and
focus on when it comes to recovery
and how could somebody theoretically
with binge eating disorder
who is at a higher weight is it possible
for them to safely lose weight without
feeling restricted and how would that
happen
it is possible the number one way it
happens is time
um it takes a long time and you have to
go through the process
so it's uncomfortable but they have to
go through the process of
understanding where the binge eating
came from to begin with
um because oftentimes what i find is
when you cut when they start the process
it's like okay weight loss that's what i
i don't [ __ ] up for my body i want to
lose weight
and i hear them and i validate that but
once we go through the actual process of
recovery and
healing their relationship with food and
therefore body
their idea of weight loss changes so
it's not necessarily that they
completely give it up or that we don't
touch it again but it we change together
the definition
of that we might focus on okay well what
does weight loss mean
for you what does health mean for you is
it about
a size oftentimes those kinds of things
are what they would say at the beginning
it's about a gene size or it's about
looking a certain way
in clothes when you go through the
process the definition
changes to something a little bit more
holistic
and that's how it can safely be done
because then their mindset is shifted to
something
much healthier than than
just a body size alone so it's it can be
done safely
it just has to be done over time and
with the right unpacking along the way
and so could somebody with binge eating
disorder ever get to the place of
being able to eat intuitively absolutely
i see it all the time it it's one of the
most
amazing things that can happen from
binging disorder that is like pretty
chaotic
in eating you can go and eat really
really intuitively
it just again takes time and trust
because ultimately it's a relationship
that's that's broken and we just have to
heal it and once your relationship with
your body
is healed and you practice that's the
other thing i tell my clients you've got
to practice it's not perfect you're
going to have days where
you don't eat intuitively because you
know
you're busy at work and you know you
need to eat and you're maybe not really
hungry but you know you have to that's
not
really intuitive but it kind of is
because you know you need it in the
bigger scheme of things
so these are the ways that we talk about
intuitive eating we make it practical
and absolutely
anyone can eat intuitively and do you
see success with implementing like
mindfulness strategies for people
who have binge eating disorder and like
what would be the most effective
mindfulness is absolutely absolutely
number one very effective
um and ultimately it's effective because
it forces the client to be aware of the
present moment which is
usually the opposite of what's happening
when they're overeating or they've been
cheating even if they're aware
some clients will say like i'm pretty
aware i've been cheating even so there's
a disconnection with your body
so mindfulness kind of brings that all
to the surface so it's things like um
unpacking you know your triggers
environmental triggers um you know
figuring out
do we have to reposition things in your
in your
kitchen do we have to reposition where
you sit at the table
screen time bowls portioning
all those kinds of things help to bring
mindfulness to the surface
as well as tons of journaling so that
helps
um at the beginning i'll have you know
clients write a ton of notes
um around their meal times i'm less
concerned with their logging of the food
and more about the context around it
because that's the mindfulness piece
and so it's very important and very
effective amazing
okay and finally what are some
strategies to help reduce that emotional
eating component
that may contribute to binge eating of
course in addition to therapy
so um so like i mentioned journaling is
very very helpful
but again it's this idea of just tuning
in to your body's cues so i like to use
introspective awareness a lot with my
clients and asking them
you know how do you can you listen to
your heartbeat
your pulse you know how do you know you
have to go to the bathroom your bladder
being full do you ever
question that like no and i'm like okay
well let's get
that's where i want you to get with food
or you don't question it your body
says gives you a message and you just do
it so that's what we're working towards
and there's little strategies
that i that i i work with clients on to
work towards that
things like hunger scales um to figure
out
where am i in terms of hunger before a
meal middle of the meal
after a meal just to compare over time
and also things like grounding
techniques i find very very effective so
similar to the mindfulness
stream um i pull from dbt
dialectical behavior therapy
modalities where they talk about using
grounding and using your senses as a
means
to ground and calm anxiety in dbt they
use it for anxiety so sometimes i use it
when we have urges for binging so we
might kind of together figure out okay
well which of your
of the five senses do you identify
strongest and if someone says you know
what i just
touch is really important to me we might
think of something that they can use
as a touch mechanism to have with them
when they are experiencing an urge or
when they're
coping through something like fuzzy
blankets or
you know like a squishy ball or a fidget
spinner or things like that
and any of the senses can have these
these very powerful
tactile grounding techniques and
strategies
so we create kind of like a an urge
tool kit using using these strategies so
that when people go into situations that
are very stressful
um around food or even when they're at
home during dealing with a meal time
you can go towards this to curb the
emotion because you're
whenever we got emotion we just gotta
ground and
get um and get present and so what about
those clients who say
i know i'm hungry i know i'm full but
i'm
what do i do about the times where i'm
hungry for the wrong foods
great question so my answer to that
would be
let's figure out why you think they're
wrong foods right because that goes back
to the mental restriction then
so even though you might say like okay
i'm i i just want i want the bad foods
the reason you want them is because you
think that they're bad there's a lot of
emotional
energy that gets charged when we have to
think that something is bad
so you know i get this question all the
time they're like but there are foods
aren't there foods that people just
shouldn't eat
like how can you be a dietitian and tell
me that like there aren't foods right
i'm sure you hear it too oh yeah all the
time
aren't there foods that we just
shouldn't eat and i say you know like of
course there is gentle nutrition of
course there's foods you should have
more often etc
but the energy that you spend trying to
villainize
those foods takes away from your
decision in that moment to make another
choice
so you don't have to choose that food
but i also don't you don't have to hate
it
let's just neutralize it so if you know
when you're hungry know when you're full
but you just want the bad foods
it's because you're thinking about bad
foods it has too much power and
potentially you're not
getting enough um food also during the
day right like if you're craving
somewhere
usually the first thing we look at with
cravings is you're not eating enough
um but when you are and there's the
physical component satisfied then we
look emotional
and we say well then you're probably
thinking that it's bad and that's why
you want it so let's do some exposure
therapy
right it's kind of the difference
between um kind of
uh physical restriction and emotional
scarcity that that
strength same kind of mentality yes yes
it's a it's a fine line between a
restriction and a boundary yeah and
that's ultimately what
recovery is about is learning what is a
boundary
and what is a restriction and knowing
that one is flexible and one is
inflexible
and that's the difference love that
flexible and inflexible that it's so
helpful
uh thank you again so much alessandra
for providing so much helpful insights
and once again everyone i'm going to be
leaving all of our contact information
in the description below so that you can
reach out if you're looking for some
one-on-one support so
thank you again my pleasure thank you so
much
bye bye thank you again to alessandra
for providing her helpful insight so
once again i'm going to be leaving
all of her contact information below if
you need to reach out for some
one-on-one support
okay so again the intention of this
review is not to diagnose
or pathologize amber lynn but to use her
content for educational purposes
to provide you with helpful insights and
knowledge
on emotional eating and the complicated
world of obesity
weight stigma and binge eating disorder
i also want to strongly remind you to
please be kind in the comments both here
and on amberlynn's channel
your words are so powerful so
please use them wisely we ultimately
cannot know what somebody is going
through
off-camera so i really do ask you guys
to consider
if your comments are helpful or
supportive
or if they contribute to the weight
stigma and discrimination
that people in larger bodies are so
often subjected to
and on that note that is all for today's
video if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]